what's up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder
and this is going to be a little bit of
a different video very candid we're
going to be talking about how scarlett
johansson
is suing disney over black widow's
theatrical slash
disney plus premiere access release
everybody's been talking about this
all morning but disney has now fired
back at her and they
weren't exactly kind they actually
kind of slammed her and now they're
saying that they are completely
in the right and scarlett johansson is
in the wrong
for those of you who may not be aware
this morning scarlett johansson filed a
lawsuit in the los
angeles superior court against disney
she claims that her contract was
breached when disney released the film
on its disney plus streaming service
at the same time as its theatrical debut
scarlett johansson said that in the suit
her agreement with disney's marvel
entertainment guaranteed an
exclusive theatrical release and her
salary was based in large part on the
box office performance of the film
and an official statement from the suit
reads disney intentionally induced
marvel's breach of the agreement without
justification
in order to prevent miss johansson from
realizing the full benefit of her
bargain
with marvel that was said in the lawsuit
so basically what scarlett johansson was
saying is
hey my salary was largely based off of
how well black widow performed in the
theaters but
then you went and released it
simultaneously on disney plus premiere
access
at the same time now obviously this kept
millions of people from going to the
theater
and watching it and spending money which
would contribute to her salary
rather they just watch it at home on
disney plus in which she's getting
either very little money from it or no
money from it since she's
claiming that most of her money was
supposed to come from the box office
well now disney has released an official
statement firing back at scarlett
johansson's lawsuit
disney responded with there is no merit
whatsoever to this filing
this lawsuit is especially sad and
distressing in its callous disregard for
the horrific
and prolonged global effects of the kova
19 pandemic
disney has fully complied with miss
johansen's contract and furthermore
the release of black widow on disney
plus with premier access has
significantly enhanced her ability to
earn
additional compensation on top of the 20
million
she has received to date so disney is
saying that this lawsuit is pretty much
bogus there's no merit
to it but they're also claiming that
she's not taken into effect what the
pandemic has done which of course
it's been hard but if her contract
clearly states that she is going to get
a theatrical release first
then they definitely violated that by
putting it on disney plus premier access
at the same time her contract was indeed
breached and that's why scarlett has
filed this lawsuit because her contract
was breached
so there's clearly merit here despite
what disney says
and they're trying to actually disregard
the merit by saying that she disregarded
the effects of the covet 19 pandemic but
really it doesn't disregard the breach
of contract
but it looks like this isn't going to be
just an easy thing it looks like there
is actually going to be a court battle
for this
scarlet clearly thinks she's right to
have filed a lawsuit against disney and
typically this doesn't come without
actually talking this through she didn't
just file a lawsuit out of nowhere she
had to have talked to some people before
expressing the breach of contract and
how unfair it was in which disney didn't
see eye to eye with her
in which she then filed the lawsuit this
is most likely what happened so they
didn't agree before
and they're definitely not to agree
again in court especially after the
statement has been released from disney
saying that there is no merit to her
lawsuit
luckily black widow is done out of the
mcu she's not supposed to make any more
appearances according to scarlett
johansson so this won't really affect
any scarlett johansson cameos in the
future
however it could severely affect premier
access on disney plus
but recently today i've been hearing
that a lot of people don't like premiere
access so
maybe it's not a terrible thing but
hopefully we can get back in the
theaters pretty soon and things will get
back to normal
but i'm very curious to hear your
thoughts about this whole situation
so please let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below
and you can always follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock as
always thank you so much for watching
woof